معنا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام الياس تابعنا في الساعه الماضيه
انطلاق دفعه صاروخيه من القطاع باتجاه
مناطق غلاف غزه كيف بدات التطورات
بعدها بالفعل سلمى وكان الاعتراض فوقنا
هنا في منطقه غلاف غزه تحديدا في منطقه
ناحى العوز ولحق ذلك ايضا دفعه صاروخيه
اخرى كانت استهدفت منطقه كيسوفيم الى ال
النوبي منا وكانت هنالك ايضا اعتراضات
صاروخيه في تلك المناطق وهذا يعكس واقع
الحال في منطقه قطاع غزه وقدره المقاومه
الفلسطينيه على تسديد هذه الضربات
الصاروخيه باتجاه منطقه غلاف غزه وايضا
باتجاه العمق الاسرائيلي عندما تريد
وقدرتها على التحكم حقيقه في ايقاع
الميدان في هذا الخصوص في تحديد المكان
والزمان والعمق الذي تستهدف فيه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بالصواريخ المناطق الاسرائيليه
لكن دعينا نشير الى ما نشاهده الان عبر
الصوره في منطقه جباليا حيث هذا الدخان
الكثيف المتصاعد من اكثر من مكان ومن اكثر
من موقع في جباليا البلد
وجباليا المخيم وهذا مؤشر على احتدام
المعارك بين القوات الاسرائيليه والمقاومه
الفلسطينيه في
تلك المناطق نحن نرى بين الحين والاخر ان
هذه الغارات الجويه هي مستمره القصف
المدفعي مستمر وكذلك الاشتباكات في
الميدان في ارض المعركه ذاتها هنالك
اشتباكات وا يعني هذه المعارك تحتدم بين
الحين والاخر نسمع ايضا الرشاشات من
العيار الثقيل
التي تشارك ايضا في عمليه الاقتحام وفي
المواجهه في تلك ال المنطقه تحديدا وهذه
المنطقه لا تهدا حقيقه سلمى منذ ايام رغم
اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي عن انتها المعارك
الكبرى في المناطق الشماليه لقطاع غزه اي
الان عدسه الكاميرا تتجه صوب المناطق
الشماليه لمدينه غزه حيث نرى ايضا ان
المشهد لا يختلف كثيرا عن ما هو الحال في
منطقه جباليا حيث ايضا حيي الدرج والتفاح
يبدو انهما يشهدان اشتباكات عنيفه بين
القوات الاسرائيليه والمقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي تتصدى للقوات الاسرائيليه في تلك الم
المطقه وكان بيان الجيش الاسرائيلي صباح
هذا اليوم قد اشار حقيقه الى وجود
اشتباكات ما زالت دائره في تلك المناطق مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه الجيش الاسرائيلي اي
عمليا في هذه في هذا التوقيت من عمر هذه
الحرب يقطع اوصال قطاع غزه الى ثلاثه
مناطق المنطقه الشماليه حيث هنالك فرقه
تعمل في تلك المنطقه هنالك فرقه في منطقه
وسط قطاع غزه ومهمتها الرئيسيه هي عمليه
الفصل ما بين المناطق الشماليه والمناطق
الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه والمهمه الرئيسيه لها
هو التاكد من ان الفلسطينيين لا يتمكنون
من العوده من المناطق الجنوبيه التي نزحوا
اليها الى مناطق شمال قطاع غزه فيما تعمل
فرقه وهي الفرقه الفرقه الاكبر في تلك
المنطقه التي تضم سبعه الويه من الجيش
الاسرائيلي في منطقه خانيونس والمناطق
الجنوبيه ويقول الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه
يواصل عمليته العسكريه في تلك المنطقه
بزخم كبير وهنالك كانت تلميحات سلمى من
جانب الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي ليله امس
بان الجيش الاسرائيلي يواصل تضييق الخناق
على القياده العسكريه والسياسيه العليا
لحركه حماس التي يعتقد بانها موجوده في
منطقه خانيونس في الانفاق الهجوميه في
اشاره الى النفق الهجومي الذي تم الكشف
عنه بالامس من جانب الناطق العسكري
الاسرائيلي والذي قال بانه اي عثر فيه على
على مقتنيات وامور تعود لبعض المحتجزين
الاسرائيليين في داخل قطاع غزه والذي
يعتقد بانهم احتجزوا في هذا النفق في
الاسابيع الماضيه وكانت التقديرات من جانب
الناطق العسكري بان 20 اسيرا اسرائيليا
على الاقل كانوا قد احتجزوا في ظروف قاسيه
وقاهره في تلك ال المناطق لكن الواضح رغم
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن نمط جديد من
العمليات العسكريه على الاقل في المنطقه
الشماليه لقطاع غزه و ويقول بانه انتقل
حقيقه الى نمط اخر لكن هذا النمط ايضا ما
زال يشهد زخما من حيث المعارك العسكريه
الضاريه تحديدا ما نشاهده الان على الشاشه
في منطقه جباليا هذه معركه حقيقيه تعيدنا
الى المعركه الكبيره التي كنا شهودا عليها
في ال 24
وال2 من الشهر ال الماضي وبعد ان خمدت هذه
المعارك لايام قليله عادت في الاسبوع
الاخير لتحت دم من جديد ونحن نرى سحب
الدخان الكثيفه المنبعثه من اكثر من مكان
في منطقه جباليا والتي تعطينا مؤشرا على
حجم المواجهه وعلى حجم المعارك الضاريه
التي تجري في تلك المنطقه لذلك عندما
يتحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي عن نمط مختلف من
العمليات العسكريه في المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه هذا لا يعني بان زخم المعارك قد
خف او قل وانما نحن نرى الان في منطقه
جباليا بان العمليات العسكريه ما زالت على
ا
وان المواجهه على الارض بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه والجيش الاسرائيلي في تتعاظم
ايضا بين الحين والاخر شكرا جزيلا لك
مراسلنا الياس كرام من منطقه غلاف غزه